aquí comienza la travesía al anochecer
en el pequeño pueblo de clavier en
italia un grupo se baja del autobús y
huye en la oscuridad
a dónde van la francia tratamos de ir a
francia francia está a menos de 3
kilómetros por carretera pero ellos
deberán caminar durante 5 horas por las
montañas son 11 personas dos familias
afganas tres niños incluyendo un pequeño
de cinco años dicen que huyeron de la
guerra en su país llegaron a europa hace
tres meses y medio
grecia
albania montenegro y bosnia
acaban de recoger ropa abrigada en una
asociación italiana
siente se siente así
miedo a la policía
a no poder llegar a francia es la
tercera vez que este grupo intenta
atravesar la frontera una patrulla de la
cruz roja italiana se cruza en su camino
en caso de emergencias llamen al 112 que
es el número de emergencias en italia y
también en francia
gracias
durante este año hemos visto muchas
familias con niños que para escapar de
los controles policiales intentan pasar
por el paso más alto que normalmente es
utilizado por los alpinistas expertos la
cuesta es cada vez más empinada la nieve
es cada vez más alta
los niños muestran los primeros signos
de cansancio
[Aplausos]
sí
no tienen frío en los pies
el grupo se orienta gracias a los puntos
gps reseñados por otros migrantes antes
de la subida
visteis
la policía es el punto azul
estamos cerca de la frontera la de
francia pase el día dos caminaron más de
cinco horas para llegar a francia
es momento de dejar a este grupo de
inmigrantes sin saber si serán detenidos
o no
en un tiene efe por esta estación de
esquí del lado francés cada año pasan
miles de inmigrantes que procuran evitar
a toda costa este puesto fronterizo
donde los campones éstos merodeadores
forman parte de un grupo de 200
voluntarios alpinistas profesionales
quienes tienen autorización para
recuperar los inmigrantes en peligro
pero no se les permite cruzar la
frontera pues de lo contrario serán
procesados por ayudar a la entrada
ilegal a territorio francés
somos merodeadores así que venimos aquí
para ver si hay gente que nos necesite
que necesite abrigo aquí estamos
comprometidos contra el terrorismo no
sabemos pero sabemos muy bien que hay
algunos de ustedes que tienen a los
migrantes y se los llevan a la policía
fronteriza donde llaman a sus colegas
efectivamente esa es la orden que
recibimos hasta luego
la policía fronteriza es reforzada por
soldados de la operación centinela en
mont tiene los controles se
restablecieron tras los atentados de
noviembre de 2015 y desde entonces la
presencia de las fuerzas del orden ha
seguido aumentando
al caer la noche aparecen siluetas en
las inmediaciones de la ciudad migrantes
de diferentes países africanos
es la cuarta vez que intentan entrar en
francia
entramos nos devuelven entramos nos
devuelven llevan cuatro días no hemos
comido ni nada
el grupo intenta esconderse pero es
descubierto rápidamente por la policía
que los detiene unos cientos de metros
más adelante pídales que salgan van a
ser expulsados expulsados no no es un
procedimiento de expulsión es una no
admisión
estos tres hombres jóvenes serán
enviados inmediatamente de vuelta a
italia
unos minutos más tarde se les suman
otras doce personas originarias de
afganistán
en la ciudad de brians son a unos 10
kilómetros de mountain es un refugio
solidario acoge a los inmigrantes que
han conseguido entrar a francia
es aquí donde encontramos a las dos
familias afganas con las que hicimos la
subida están en situación irregular
tienen que presentar una solicitud de
asilo para ponerse en regla pero aún no
saben si lo harán en francia o en
alemania
tengo que pensar si pido asilo en
francia en todas partes tendré seguridad
para mí y educación para mis dos hijos
podría hacerlo
las dos familias descansarán unos días
en brians son antes de retomar el camino
por su cuenta desde 2017 casi 12.000
personas han pasado por este refugio
inmigrantes a los que nada parece poder
detener ni la policía ni estas cumbres
nevadas